So, when you're walking into a brick and
mortar store in the real world.
It's pretty obvious that you're
going to put down some money and
you're going to buy something.
Is that similar for apps?
>> Yes and no.
If you wish to charge user
before they download your app,
you can do it in a simple way.
First, create a Merchant Account.
Second, set the prices for
your app in the Developer Console.
Third, you can optionally
include advertising or
use In-app billing to sell
additional features or content.
Web links to all the three stages
in the instructor notes down below.
It's important to remember
who are you targeting?
Since this model may limit your
app monetization potential.
Particularly in developing market.
You may be able to achieve greater
revenue by using the freemium or
subscription models.